[MUSIC- MAYDAY]
MAYDAY: Hello.
We are Mayday, November 28.
YouTube live streaming
concert.
At Google headquarters.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC- MAYDAY]
MARVIN CHOW: Everybody.
[MANDARIN]
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome Mayday,
the band from China.
[APPLAUSE]
MARVIN CHOW: Please,
please sit down.
Welcome to Google, everybody.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
MARVIN CHOW: Are you excited?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Very, excited.
Very, very excited.
MARVIN CHOW: It's Like every
other company you've been to?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
It's quite very different.
It's a lot of passion here.
We can feel that.
MARVIN CHOW: That is us, we
are all about the passion.
Why don't we start, tell us--
I think you have the
concert tonight.
You've been on the road
for ten days.
How is it going?
What are you thinking about
the concert tonight?
What are your expectations?
MALE SPEAKER 2:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: We have great
expectations for today's concert.
This is the first of its kind,
that we are holding.
And then we are hoping to
interact with our fans across
the world tonight
over YouTube.
MARVIN CHOW: Any surprises
tonight?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Surprise?
Maybe some one will be naked.
MARVIN CHOW: Oooh.
Which one?
MALE SPEAKER 2: You.
The one spoken, you.
Just kidding.
MARVIN CHOW: It's officially
on YouTube.
So it's going to be true, so.
But speaking of YouTube, you
know, you are the most viewed,
most followed, most searched for
Chinese band in the world.
And as you guys have been around
for a long time, what
do you think the future of kind
of C-pop is in America?
And then around the world.
MALE SPEAKER 3:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: So in the past,
you may think that you can
find some impersonal and
unemotional information on,
via Google search engine.
But today we want to show you
that not only you can find
information via Google search
engine, but also emotional
music contents that we
brought to the world.
MARVIN CHOW: And that goes, so
I think, you know, in today's
world social media
is very big.
You're big on Google+, I'm
sure, in other platforms.
How is your role on these
different social media
platforms helping your career,
your music, and your fan base?
MALE SPEAKER 3:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: Something that very
excites us is we'll be
able to use a platform like
Google+ to directly interact
with our fan base.
Not through other medias
or channels.
And that's something that we
think, it's very necessary in
today's world.
MARVIN CHOW: I don't know if
you know this, but when we
look at the data, your band is
probably one of the top ten
bands in the world-- entities
in the world--
in terms of engagement
with fans.
So commenting, liking, +1, and
so I think your fan base is
clearly very interested in
everything you have to say.
MALE SPEAKER 3:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MARVIN CHOW: Keep going.
TRANSLATOR: Are we really
the top ten?
MALE SPEAKER 3:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: We are surprised.
Is it really so?
MARVIN CHOW: Look
at everybody.
Your love is huge.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Actually, we
didn't know we had lots of
fans in US right now.
I think so.
MARVIN CHOW: You're about to
have many more after tonight.
MALE SPEAKER 1: OK.
Please cheer for us, yes.
MARVIN CHOW: So,
I mean, talking
about being in America.
We are talking backstage that
you were in Atlantic City last
night, or before, and one
of you lost $100,000.
And, naw, I'm just kidding.
I'm totally kidding.
You know, but tell us what it's
like, being In Atlantic
City and obviously traveling
around America.
What's been surprising?
What's been interesting?
MALE SPEAKER 4:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: There's always
a nice surprise for us
everywhere we go in the world.
And one of the most interesting
thing for us is,
we cannot imagine before we came
over here what our fans
look like in such a far
place in the world.
And once we meet them, and see
them swaying, and singing to
our music, we just feel that
it's such a powerful
experience for all of us.
MARVIN CHOW: So then besides
New Jersey, where is your
favorite place in the world that
you guys have traveled
and performed to?
MALE SPEAKER 1: I think it's
definitely one place, but it
hasn't happened.
It's just tonight.
In Google headquarters.
I think it's not only singing at
Google because it's singing
to lots, lots--
it's millions of people.
And it's part of the future.
It's internet and you
can connect with
people without seeing.
Just listen.
And didn't have to touch.
And its information
transmission.
I think it's very exciting
for tonight.
MARVIN CHOW: So if you weren't
a world famous music band, do
you think you'd be working
at Google?
MALE SPEAKER 2: Sure
we want to.
But it's not about if
we want or not,
it's about your ability.
So I heard that it's
hard to work here.
So maybe all the guys work here
wearing a black t-shirt.
Maybe you're one of the
most intelligent
people in the world.
Maybe.
But we are not so intelligent.
MARVIN CHOW: You're doing OK.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Really?
MARVIN CHOW: But if you weren't
singing, because
obviously it's a very
hard profession.
Have you guys thought about
what would you be doing?
What are the other passions that
you would be pursuing?
MALE SPEAKER 5:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MALE SPEAKER 3:
MALE SPEAKER 5:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: First choice.
Is definitely being
a Google engineer.
They saw a lot of bicycles
parked downstairs.
And he's thinking that this must
be a great, fun, and easy
place to work at.
MARVIN CHOW: So easy.
We, in the middle of the
day we just break
to hang with Mayday.
Maybe if you talk to the Google
Taiwan team they can
get you some bicycles
back home.
We'll work on that for you.
On the music, a little bit, I
think a lot of people have
talked about the Beatles
compared to you.
And I understand that
they're are a major
influence on your music.
Can you talk about kind of the
influences on your music and
the relationship with
the Beatles?
MALE SPEAKER 3:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: So back when they
were young, they've had
challenging times.
And it was the Beatles music
that helped them through the
difficult times.
But back in those days, it was
a little difficult to find
Beatles music.
But now we are so fortunate to
have a platform like YouTube,
where you can just search
any music that you
want to listen to.
MARVIN CHOW: So was there
a Beatles song that
really was your song?
MALE SPEAKER 4:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MALE SPEAKER 2:
MALE SPEAKER 4:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
"Let It Be."
MALE SPEAKER 2:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MALE SPEAKER 3: I think
mine is "In My Life."
MALE SPEAKER 5: What
about "Yesterday?"
MALE SPEAKER 4:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MALE SPEAKER 1:
[SINGING]
It's long and winding road.
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MALE SPEAKER 3: Yes.
Yes sir.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
"Gangnam Style" [MANDARIN].
TRANSLATOR: They want a live
performance of "Gangnam
Style."
MALE SPEAKER 2:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: Save it
till tonight.
MARVIN CHOW: It must be
interesting, I mean, you guys
have been singing for
over 20 years.
What do you think of "Gangnam
Style", and PSY, what's
happening in the world?
MALE SPEAKER 1: I think it's
the power of the music.
And power of the internet.
You don't have to know
something like--
you don't have to really
understand the language.
So there is no limit, no
boundary, and no, no gaps
between what we are speaking.
and what we are, the words.
It's all about music.
The passion and the heart.
So just feel the heart, then
you can feel the music.
MARVIN CHOW: It's
very powerful.
So one of the things that is
kind of a Google tradition,
with regular meetings or when
world famous bands come, is we
ask the employees questions.
And they get to vote and ask
questions of the guests.
And so we have a couple
questions from the fans.
So the first question is from
Ming, is Ming here?
Or is a Ming here?
The question is my band is going
on debut next February.
But we haven't had a name yet.
Can you please give us a name?
Is that person here?
Your band?
Come here.
I think maybe if he sings a
little bit for you, you can
help him name the band.
MING: I'm not a vocalist.
Actually I play the drums.
MARVIN CHOW: So if you look at
him, what do you think we
should name his band?
MALE SPEAKER 3: June.
MARVIN CHOW: June.
MALE SPEAKER 3: It's like,
you know, June day.
Girl's name.
MARVIN CHOW: OK.
You are now June.
Congratulations.
MING: Oh, really?
MARVIN CHOW: Thank
you very much.
MING: Thank you.
MARVIN CHOW: The second question
is from Mayday fan in
Mountain View.
How frequently do
you use Google+?
What kinds of opportunities do
you think social networking
products can bring to
the music industry?
MALE SPEAKER 2:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: So the last time
I use Google+ was about 30
minutes ago.
And actually recently I've
found a lot of music
professionals to collaborate
with among my fan page.
And all of you know, once you
become famous artist, it's
hard to make friends
outside the world.
And then Google+ is a platform
where I can do so
and meet new people.
MARVIN CHOW: The next question
is what's your favorite song?
Non-Beatles song.
I'm guessing Mayday
song, maybe?
MALE SPEAKER 3:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: Hard to answer
this question.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Yeah, it's
a big, big question.
MALE SPEAKER 4:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MALE SPEAKER 3:
TRANSLATOR: So actually the
last song I heard was last
night on YouTube.
And it's a song passed over
from my friend in
my Google+ fan page.
And I thought that this is a
great platform for us to
discover not only music and
songs from unknown artists, as
well as well known artists.
MARVIN CHOW: Do we have
a live question?
Anyone here?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First I would like to say happy
birthday to Monster.
It's your birthday today.
Yeah, happy birthday.
And I'm going to ask a really
common, but everyone want to
know the answer.
That is, do you have any plan to
have an outdoor, open, huge
concert in the Bay Area?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Outdoor,
maybe.
Bay Area?
Not far from here.
We are, we are going to
play Sports Arena in
LA on February 2.
And it's full concert.
We will ship our equipment
from Asia to here.
So it's full, full
Mayday concert.
So please welcome.
Everybody in the US and in the
San Francisco, hope all of you
can be there.
See you.
MARVIN CHOW: We're getting
ready to wrap it up.
Is there anything you
would like to share
with the fans at Google?
Anything upcoming or any words
that you would like to share
with the group here?
MALE SPEAKER 2:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: Everyone please
remember to tune in at 7:00 PM
sharp to the YouTube
live streaming of
their concert tonight.
And also remember to interact
and post your lives and
thoughts, on Google+ frequently
because that's
where Mayday is searching
for their next
collaborative partner.
MARVIN CHOW: Question
from the audience?
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MALE SPEAKER 4:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MALE SPEAKER 5:
MALE SPEAKER 1:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: This question is
about their Taiwanese?
How good their Taiwanese is.
And I think it's obvious that
Ming doesn't speak Taiwanese.
MARVIN CHOW: Shh.
We won't tell anyone.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MARVIN CHOW: We have
another question.
AUDIENCE: I was always curious
to find out if there was the
meaning behind the
French bread.
Like the [MANDARIN], what
was the story behind it?
MALE SPEAKER 3: Oh you
mean the French bread
in the music video?
AUDIENCE: The videos, yeah.
Because we always, every time
we went KTV we would just
like, love that song.
And be dancing everywhere.
And like, we even one
time had a party and
brought French bread.
And we're hitting each
other with it.
MALE SPEAKER 3: Actually
we have the same
questions with you.
You know, we are not a director
of the music video.
But that's the idea of the
music video director.
So every time I saw the music
video, I have the same
question with you.
What happened with
the French bread?
MALE SPEAKER 4:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MALE SPEAKER 3: Yeah, maybe
you can Google it.
Many forums, many people
discuss about that.
But I'm not a director.
AUDIENCE: I went
to UC Berkeley.
And like a lot of-- in TSA
we always had parties.
And the French bread with
like a really big thing.
Everybody had like
the [MANDARIN].
Every time we had a party, or
KTV contest the [MANDARIN].
MALE SPEAKER 2:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: There's nothing to
like about us, besides the
French bread?
MARVIN CHOW: You guys should
get a bread sponsorship.
All right, one more question.
I think there was
one, this young
gentleman here, very eager.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: In terms of writing
music, when you run
into difference in opinions,
how do you settle that?
MALE SPEAKER 2:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
TRANSLATOR: But we're
a democratic group.
So we voice our opinions
and then we vote.
But lately, we let the richest
guy among us, to decide.
MARVIN CHOW: It's just
like at Google.
MALE SPEAKER 3:
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
MARVIN CHOW: Everybody,
thank you very much.
Please give it up for Mayday.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC- MAYDAY]
TRANSLATOR: Thank you.
Thank you.